dans la trésorerie pour payer ton de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix si on
veut continuer à vendre nos business on
est obligé on a des crédits sur la tête
si on paye pas la facture d'électricité
si on commence à faire n'importe quoi
on a derrière on a des problèmes plus
graves donc on tape dans la trésorerie
on n'a pas le choix c'est clair
moi aussi moi vraiment je vous conseille
mais c'est mes héros tous ces mecs qui
sont patrons là en ce moment qui est qui
accepte de donner 60 000 € de leur
trésorerie pour sauver les emplois des
Français parce qu'ils sauvent des
emplois des mecs ils sauvent des
salariés c'est-à-dire que moi en tant
que patron je me dis est-ce que moi
j'aurais les coronaises de mettre 60 000
€ tous les mois en plus pour sauver mes
salariés je sais même pas si je le ferai
sincèrement
je respecte beaucoup parce que depuis
l'âge de 20 ans est-ce que tu as tu as
travaillé toute ta vie pour mettre de
l'argent de côté pour avoir un
trésorerie juste comme ça parce que on a
décidé les politiques ont décidé de
faire des choix de merde et de payer
60000 euros tu la reverras plus les 60
000 €